i have about
four more of these at home different
like shapes and sizes but this is my
favorite one because i think she looks
really good in this one this is huge in
the carpool lane this is huge what's up
gq i'm noah beck and these are my 10
essentials
[Music]
all right
sorry dixie but this is my first true
love growing up soccer was my passion
transitioning from
wanting to be a
soccer football player to
what i'm doing now it's the hardest
decision i've ever had to make but
opportunities were too good not to take
and i kind of just had to
roll the dice if you will on my future
wherever i go this will always be in the
trunk of my car no matter what i mean i
want to do a youtube video take this to
santa monica and just like pass it to
people or like be like all right me and
you 1v1
i think this one and the soccer ball
kind of go hand in hand like the soccer
ball is really there for any reason like
i could play street with that i can go
to an actual field but like these like
determine like
all right we playing for real these are
always in the trunk of my car as well
always i got these in paris on my recent
trip and here in la fields are like
scarce here like there's no
fields like they're very like limited
access here even if it's turf like they
have it locked up and everything like
you can't just go play which
it's very hard to like get practice on
your own but in france total opposite
these fields
grass turf whatever it is these fields
are open to everyone and
i wanted to like
take advantage of that and that's been
my goal since i was a kid to play soccer
in europe obviously the circumstances
are a little different where i was there
for a fashion brand got these cleats and
i and i told the brand if we have time
in the morning i want to go kick a ball
around like i just want to go play on
one of these fields and we did played a
little 3v3 against some local french
kids
beat them obviously
soccer is kind of like my therapy have
that time with their friends and just
hang out play sports like that that's
probably one of my favorite things to do
actually of my essentials right here is
my dixie pillow this was actually
gifted to me by uh
i'm pretty sure his name on instagram is
uh the pillow guy he reached out and
asked if i wanted any pillows and i said
yes make me a dixie pillow it's actually
funny because daisy and i both have like
weird pieces of merch of each other like
i have no idea where she got it but she
has a dress filled with like pictures of
me she has like socks with like my name
on it she has
like just random t-shirts saying like
i'm dating noah beck
it's a bit cringe honestly but it's also
pretty cute i think she just came to my
room one day and just saw like i have
all these pillows positioned on my couch
and it literally looks like i have a
bunch of dixies over it literally it's
kind of creepy but at the same time it's
just funny and it's just like troll at
this point but
yeah there's
about four or five dixie just sitting on
my couch
when she's out of town
i'll cuddle up with this just as like a
reminder i really need a case for it
obviously because my mic falls off but
uh my vlog camera everyone
typically like before i even did social
media when someone said like a vlog
camera i assumed like
very easy like a little tiny camera and
like some people use that but this is my
vlog camera it's kind of a
heavy duty one yeah need this with me at
all times in case something fun happens
or in case
i
get an idea of just like oh we should
shoot this being a youtuber this kind of
just represents like putting
my life on the internet if you're an og
or if you remember if you i mean you
don't have to be you can just go back
into my feed my first ever
tick tock video
was filmed in my sister's room usually
you would use like a ring light or some
kind of lighting source i used my
sister's laptop and i literally looked
up white on google went to images
clicked on a white screen zoomed in on
it and then turned the brightness all
the way up but it worked i guess and my
first video did pretty well for me
having zero followers woke up to like 20
000 followers so that was pretty cool
that video did like 100k when i upgraded
from my sister's laptop i
actually went in and got a flashlight
from the kitchen and like i literally
put a nail right here and narrow here
and then rested the flashlight on it so
the flashlight was facing me on my wall
it almost looked too
good like the lighting was almost too
good where it was kind of like creepy
i'd like to say i've progressively
gotten better in terms of like quality
and like the production but to this day
like i i i sometimes use flashlights
yeah this kind of represents just like
hygiene cologne i like to smell good i
like to
this i i didn't bring deodorant but
obviously also deodorant
yeah this is a special clone so i was on
a tic toc live once and someone
commented like what kind of clone do you
use i think someone just wanted to know
what kind of cologne i used and i told
them i went to my bathroom and i
literally showed them i was like i use
like invictus paco robone or paco ribo
i'm not sure how you name it and
literally a week later i get a package
from
paco ribone and
they sent me like four bottles of
cologne like different
like different scents from this
collection this one has my name engraved
into it like i didn't sharpen this on or
anything like this came like this that
was a cool moment i was like
i'll start showing off other things on
my lives too you know just get little
packages probably one of my favorite
compliments too is like when someone
walks by and they're like you smell good
next noah beck essential is
just like nutrition
take care of your body
water is very important i drink just
around a gallon a day
i have this protein bar here if you need
like a quick meal replacement if you
miss a meal still got to get the
calories in
got to have your protein bar with you at
all times so if you're with your friends
and you guys haven't had like a meal in
a while
your car stops middle of the freeway
let's say just having car problems
they're hungry they're starving we're in
the middle of nowhere i got my gym bar
they don't
and like if you think i'm sharing
i probably will but that's beside the
point like if they had a gym bar i
wouldn't have to share
big basketball guy love basketball it's
fun to play with the friends and i'm a
huge sons fan
obviously
pretty rough ending to the season i'm a
big shoe guy big big uh
sneaker head if you will so i got my
purple kobe's i saw booker wearing these
like they looked really good with the
jerseys like the all black ones love
basketball it's super fun to play and
plus playing pickup basketball with like
three of your friends versus three other
guys like give you 30 minutes you'll
burn like 800 to 1000 calories to be
honest like basketball i swear just
somehow you burn crazy amount of
calories you're just always moving i
obviously before kobe passed um
was a huge kobe fan still am in terms of
like his work ethic and his mentality
it's
it was truly like admirable the way he
thought about the game
it's something like even when i played
soccer it's some he's someone that i
kind of i idolized i love a good fitted
cap i think if i'm having a bad hair day
just throw this on and this is obviously
arizona diamondbacks kind of hard to be
a fan of them right now not having the
best season but
is what it is this actually has a cool
story behind it because this was the hat
that i wore in the mlb celeb game that i
went to this year and that was an
amazing experience there's usually
probably one in my car you guys probably
think my car is like a mess i promise
you because i just said everything's in
my car i promise you it's just in the
trunk like i have like compartments in
my trunk i'm a very clean guy i promise
you that
just a deck of cards cards are
definitely an essential yeah this kind
of just represents like all like games
i'm a big board game guy i love strategy
games katan i love
risk there's a game called o'hell does
anyone know
anyone heard of that no
okay game nights are one of my favorite
things to do it's so fun
i would take that
over going out any day of the week i
love
hanging out with friends like fun
genuine people that you just have a good
time with don't think i i like have game
nights with the boys with louis vuitton
playing cards these were the first
things i found so yeah don't come at me
for that i love a good black t-shirt
like
i just feel like you can't go wrong you
can literally pair a black t-shirt with
anything
a black t-shirt could be worn with jeans
it can be worn with black pants it can
be worn with
cargo like
black t-shirt like i love a good black
t-shirt if i if i don't know what to
wear i'll throw on a black t-shirt and
just match anything with it it's casual
it could be nice like
you can go anywhere with that fit all
right gq thank you guys so much for
allowing me to share a little bit more
about myself through my essentials you
guys know where to follow me at noaa
back on all my platforms